hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to 60 seconds a
happy-go-lucky happy sounding game about
atomic drill apocalypse cabbage and
survival oh no those are the game types
I am horribly mistaken I don't know how
to play this game so I'm going to do the
atomic drill learn all about how to
scavenge and survive in the event of a
nuclear apocalypse this tutorial is a
hundred percent approved by the
establishment okay I'm gonna speed
through this one so you guys don't have
to put up with me being stupid and
everyone knows the music's gonna cut out
now okay nevermind welcome your atomic
scavenge drill pay attention and you
might just make it okay I've run
stupidly also the camera turns like I'm
an idiot
nice tuba or is that a baritone you're
doing well honey don't make me get that
gun off the wall you keep practicing or
else hello wife thank you for putting up
with my horrible ugliness I can't wait
to make love to you once a month it's
gonna be great so I'm gonna go off to a
yellow X because a strange drill
sergeant in my brain tells me what to do
with my life isn't that delightful ahaha
find your son Timmy ASAP okay hi Timmy
how's it going good thing you know the
layout of your house I bet you're the
Reds know it too why would that crazy
voice inside my head I have no idea
grab Timmy what why am i grabbing him
okay I just stuffed him inside my pocket
that's totally okay can I grab her -
whatever her name is my daughter of some
sort okay find the highlighted soup can
grab it excuse me not very important
which soup can in here where's the hi oh
there okay Wham got it soup an excellent
choice this can sustain a family of four
for a day why and how also only if we
have a can opener water bottle good idea
in the laundry room okay whatever I'm
not gonna clay to the shelter okay bad
yard where's the hatch
I get the basic gist of this Oh it's
inside my house that's awfully handy
this is what keeps you safe your family
and your supplies safe it's hard to miss
yeah I miss
did somehow don't know how but I did
drop whatever you're hearing down there
Wham
Judy you'll be fine don't worry about
the broken bones they heal up in no time
the radiation makes them grow super good
okay small stockpile of food water and
even little Timmy yep that's all I need
a groan dad whamming and bam and his way
through the apocalypse gonna be good no
one knows how long you'll be staying
down there so you'll need a radio will I
now don't tell me what to do voice in my
head that tells me what to do I'm fun
Wham nice turtle anybody at all anybody
excuse me pardon me anybody I'm talking
to nobody in particular can't find your
radio check the living room ah of course
where my lovely wife was hiding it from
me because she's a commie
oh no wait this is my bedroom sorry wife
I was mistaken anyway that's it nothing
more useful to news from the outside I'm
sure it'll be fine
Timmy what's that you fractured your
skull great that'll keep the commies out
of this good enough here comes the hard
part uh surviving trying to deal with
all the voices inside my head not
flooding into everything the extra
seconds before the siren sounds to scout
you're here roundings after that you
need to start packing great 500k huh all
right I'm ready our incredibly advanced
warning system gives you 60 secs ago I
wanna tell you barring a piece of cake
on the deck of cards and this horsey
then I'm gonna ride off into the sunset
it's gonna be magical is there a key for
this
ah this uh uh what are you huh how about
this and uh well I want to use how about
this
oh god I'm almost out of time I better
worry about my family member no way more
soup
love me some soup lifts how about you
can I get you
hello you two can I also key oh no my
daughter's too big I can't carry it all
ah come on come here wife come here wife
you look like you're used to this kind
of behavior I shouldn't know about it
but you know I ain't gonna question it
none too much this and you to the
shelter I go I'm the best terrorized the
best sir over could be the best husband
the west the best father something else
I don't know to the shelter I go home
Utley I got enough yeah okay we're
almost there wolves deer almost there
almost there
oh god not enough time oh god there's
one more thing nevermind oh there's not
I brought you two got in that flashlight
that would have been good can I Drive it
has arrived now you know what you need
to do but your training is far from over
[ __ ] I'm gonna get right into the
apocalypse oh [ __ ] you I'll see you
downstairs for survival training
Addie's I'll figure that out on my own
wait
I'm sure I'll be fine Timmy broke my
fall with all his broken bones
okay well that seemed good what's that
okey-dokey then day one you made it to
the shelter congratulations but the
drills not over yet you'll end up here
with whatever and whoever you brought
with you nothing else you'll need to
make the most of it the next few days
will teach you how to survive down here
while the world outside birds explore
and interact with your surroundings you
can always find things useful about your
shelter and its inhabitants when your
survival journal is not open you know
hidden pressing first we must ration
food and water if you don't wine and
dine yourself in the folks you've
brought with you you can bet your bottom
dollar none of you will ever see the
light of day again as long as you have
food and water available ration it out
to a given person by selecting the
picture of a can of bottle
the portrait or instantly ration out
both by clicking on the characters image
of course you might save supplies for
later but a normal person can only
survive four days without water as to
food the longer you deny your people
rations the weaker they will get and it
might eventually get sick even if you
manage to cure them it will take you
quite a few cans and a lot of time to
replenish their strength time to ration
supplies okey-dokey then
Dada we did it we're going point point
okay who's gonna go on an expedition
sending people out to the wasteland is
no walk in the park do it early without
a gas mask then you can bet it's a
suicide mission for them said healthy
and well-fed people sick her crazed
people are more likely to perish out
there you can send one person at a time
let's give it a try time you need to
send someone out but if you ever want to
skip a trip to the surface don't select
anyone you I'm gonna go I'm the data
situation I'm gonna volcano D that soup
can looked like someone trying to eat a
whole and then pooping it back out and
erect their lower intestines probably
what happened I'm an army man so I don't
know a second thing about imagination
but you could probably use yours now
picture this scenario you come across
your kids hamster who in some bizarre
way found its way to the shelter the
kids are obviously going to love it and
so will you there's nothing better than
food that comes to you on its own now
it's up to you do you cook them
absolutely yes sounds good I like it
hmm it's gonna be great cooked hamster
delicious Wow again that super cam looks
like just a bunch of blood put into a
tin can and then it was shat out by
someone good choice everyone had a fresh
bite and fresh meat will not be as easy
to come by in the days head has to take
any chance you can get to eat believe me
you will find yourself in your family in
much more dire circumstances at this and
there won't be a hamster around to save
your ass by eating its own ass but not
in a sexy way it's impressive how well
Mary Jane is handling the situation she
looks fine today Danny seems okay radio
is critical to establishing
communication with the US Army as well
as for listening out any trouble blah
blah blah expedition is back
mother supplies radiation sickness blah
blah blah blah blowing in the dark is
not as fun as it sounds maybe it will be
for Dolores some days we get very
intense a lot of things will happen that
you need to be prepared for blah blah
blah blah Timmy's back blah blah blah
more soup more water blah blah got a
flashlight as you were counting
imaginary sheep in your head another
series of knocks broke your
concentration someone is really
hammering on your door and probably not
taking no for an answer
- knocks - knocks the pattern keeps
repeating do you open the door hell yeah
I'm so down for that
- knocks ready baby rescue me yeah oh
okay
hey okay I did it
good job me who safes down with our
brave soldiers house the rabble pie it's
AB radiation sickness great okay
now that I'm passive tutorial and I've
learned everything that I'm supposed to
be learning hopefully that zoomed right
by I don't know if it did but hopefully
it did if it did not well okay boy we're
gonna try an apocalypse which I'm pretty
sure Tsar Bomba
well [ __ ] I'm I'm totally down for this
we're gonna do this everybody ready for
that if a Tsar Bomba
went off which was the 50-megaton uh
atomic bomb that would not be good okay
I'm ready I'm so ready I'm ready for
this I'm ready I'm gonna grab my wife
then I'm gonna grab my gun and then I'm
gonna do something that I probably gonna
regret here we go come here wife
give me a wife to the shelter to the
shelter oh I'm skedaddling as fast as I
can skedaddle come here you come here
are you good did you get some of you I
don't know where you are but to the
shelter we go BAM
smash doodle oh god diner come here
you're so up healthy and large and
healthy wise our soup in the fireplace
that doesn't make any goddamn sense damn
I need that gas mask I need it now okay
I got a gas mask and I need a nap
checkerboard sure good enough I don't
know where the radio was [ __ ] I'm a bad
dad I'm a bad daddy
oh god I'm not gonna give you able to
get the radio I don't know whether read
don't see the radio
oh god this bad this bad this bad
this bad this bad I don't know where the
radio is I don't know where the radio is
Oh God no rum oh [ __ ] shitty tits well
[ __ ] no rum Oh goddamn it I'm doing so
badly oh we're gonna die oh we're gonna
die okay I guess I can't grab anything
else off we go then oh boy
that didn't go well I didn't get
anything that I needed I'm gonna die
horribly but at least I'll be with my
family
hooray we got no food no water and no
hope boo got a gas mask all right let's
do this all right so we got more water
than I thought we did all of us made it
into the shelter just seconds before the
blast we can't remember bringing those
supplies down the shelter but we're not
complaining we probably should have
stocked better anyway you goddamn right
we did our shelves are full of cans
believe from the cans well sleep on the
cans talk to the cans some of us re do
plenty of water we don't have to worry
about that for some time okay don't
don't don't point good thing we can
rascism food better than we can ration
water we decided to have some fun day
play a game or two the first one was
picking the games we were gonna play
took his most today still have made up
her mind well that sounds fun what a
happy family adventure that we're gonna
have oh boy I can't wait to die horribly
neighborhood still highly radioactive
trips to the surface of big risk tandas
vigorous enough to withstand the hazards
of the wasteland
Dolores wasteland no match for Mary Jane
and why is that is she gonna blast them
all with her baritone all right so I'm
gonna send out Ted yeah we should start
preparing for an expedition we really
got a whole hell shelter has been
shaking every couple of minutes and it
feels like it's getting stronger every
time it happens here it comes again and
it's way worth it's an earthquake hold
on to something the gas masks
oh god please please am I gonna lose the
flashlight what about our shadow puppets
Oh God we'll be so out of me who's but
we have to talk to each other
all right everyone okay what's up so we
need to make a proper inspection we
never used to get such bad ones before
it's all because of the atoms definitely
the atoms
no one should mess with atoms no one
it's always better we take your car
luckily nothing to happen to Mary dated
Oh action
nevermind whoops what to take outside
how about the gas mask because that's
kind of important all right
you go get him buddy you get him
buckaroo shoulda sent you with a gun but
whatever that don't matter
it's all right okay so he's gone but
that means we have left to ration out at
least we'll have enough water for one
more day this is terrible we can't sleep
we've been having problems sleeping ever
since we got down here but now it's
worse than ever we don't deal with this
problem we won't be able to cope with
any other challenges that await us
outside these thin shelter doors so what
does that have to do with this there's
some sleeping pills in their search
morphine to knock us out
oh yay okay I don't know what that did
our first-aid kit was well stocked with
a variety of medical supplies including
a pack of sleeping pills
we never thought we would use them but
in the condition it's in right now also
was nice change from her usual diet of
tomato soup we're all rested now can
enjoy our time in the shelter or camping
yeah it was only sleeping pills in there
oh the bandages and [ __ ] went away after
using it okay so Ted okay mom gets water
because mom best we tried to keep track
of dates but they just don't add up
luckily Tim Lee remembered is his
birthday today we should give him the
present or a cake or both so it's
settled we're making a soup cake but
what about the gift what is it gonna
disappear
I guess the checkerboard but yeah does
that mean we don't get to use it or is
it just gonna break it because curious
masturbation takes a lot of effort huh
if tad doesn't come back with some
supplies pronto
we are dunzo oh my god he's not back is
he dead he's dead is he
oh he's dead we're dead he's dead where
he we have he's we're all dead
we're dead we're dead we're dead Oh Ted
Ted are we dead oh you got food Ted Oh
Ted you got lock and key I don't know
what the hell that's gonna do for us but
yeah lock and key good job Ted Oh
oh man I really opened only last ten
days because otherwise we're gonna be
dead that gotta be super duper dead okay
we need to give water to everybody
everyone gets fruit and water everyone
okay so we need to pack up for an
expedition because if we don't we're
going to die what's that sound a
galloping horse we rested the door and
we're greeted by two men dressed like
they come from the deiville fair we
identified the foreign source of the
sound one of the most holding two rocks
and hitting them against each other
constantly while the other was skipping
and pretending to be a rider they said
they're looking for some antique Cup but
they got lost and they would be most
grateful if let us check our map
provided we have one okay cool what are
they gonna give us in return something
good maybe anything anything at all
again another shat out can of soup they
got us a Boy Scout Handbook oh they seem
friendly enough so we let them have a
look at our map they thanked us and
officers replies we got a Boy Scout
Handbook that doesn't seem like it's
gonna incredibly help us okay everyone
gets rations and then someone's going
outside
dolorous because they said that no match
for the Dolores so the Lord's going out
there with a gun cuz I trust her more
than myself and my son hopefully she'll
be back soon otherwise we're gonna be
dead all right point point point
you know you'd think that some of the
soup would be able to give you some
water
spiders seem to be operating under the
assumption that they have all the same
rights to the shelter as we do they're
everywhere and don't seem very scared of
us it's time we change that we don't
want any more spiders in our soup no sir
okay am I gonna squash him with a Boy
Scout Handbook and then it's gonna be
infected with spiders that we're gonna
have to throw it away is that what it is
also we have a bottled water look we
always knew books were precious they are
the perfect weapon for waging total war
on insectoids of every place while
chasing them around we found a misplaced
bottle of water that was a good hunt
yeah very responsible in the face of the
apocalypse you guys are doing
wonderfully okay there we go enough
water for everybody eventually we were
never fan when we were never huge fans
of mushrooms but with the colony of them
growing on one of the walls we changed
our loyalties we're all about mushrooms
now should we eat them yeah sure what's
the worst gonna happen we have a drug
trip one of us dies oh whatever who know
Oh Dolores Oh Dolores oh don't I maybe
you should have had a gas mask I don't
know the gun did you did the doing any
good Oh No or Mary Jane sorry
oh no that was Mary Jane Oh Dolores was
supposed to go out out tits
Oh No we are going to die we are dead we
are dead we are dead we're dead we are
dead we're dead and someone knocked on
the door we were suspicious and cautious
but after a few minutes of talking it
turned out it was just a group of old
ladies where I have a tea party not from
where with the bombs were dropped we
thought it would be a good only good
manners to talk to them face to face
when we open the door those old bats
attacked us with their umbrellas canes
and something that looked like a spike
table like we need to fight back how
about a gun I'm down for guns let's
shoot some old ladies who are gone rabid
and wild kaboom
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] my gun no no the gunfight
was intense but our position gave us the
advantage we needed to drive those thugs
away one of them even lost an axe while
retreating
and they're dead because I shot them and
they're dead
we're dead too if we don't survive this
and you know what we're we're dead we're
dead we're dead we're dead we're dead we
can't make contact with the military's
because I forgot my radio we're dead
we're dead well dead we're gonna die
deadly we're gonna definitely die so
much death is gonna be part of us we're
dead
oh we're so dead oh we're so dead now
we're so dead oh we're so dead oh we're
also dead alright you go with you go
with an axe I guess oh we're so dead
even though Delores looks totally fine
in the face of adversity but we're so
dead we're so dead oh we're so dead Tim
looks fine sobbing we better give her
some food today or else oh boy yeah
Timmy's in terrible shape needs water Oh
everyone's dead everyone's dead
everyone's dead all dead we're dead
we're dead why are we surviving 17th
days they're dead oh they're dead
oh they're dead oh no oh no lack of
water drove Timmy insane ran away
he's a boiling point where her stare was
enough to kill she left without a word
probably become a Highway woman to get
all the food cans you would ever need
well that's that's that's weird to talk
about your daughter like that oh boy
we're dead we're dead
knock knock this sound always surprises
and confuses us it could mean anything
good or bad but we're always curious
should we open it yeah cuz we got
nothing better to do
we're dead oh [ __ ] oops oh boy well that
doesn't look good
I
something went horribly wrong oh well
turned out it was nice mysterious fellow
in a weird suit he put some soup cans
the Swamper survived a couple days oh
man
Dolores is coming we not coming back oh
no oh no oh no I didn't get the radio ah
damn it okay
well it was fun that was a good that was
really fun I had a great time with that
that was really fun and I died but it
was fun so yeah so that was sixty
seconds that was literally that was a
ton of fun I would love to play this
again but I would like your opinion on
whether or not you would like to see it
again
so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought in
the comments down below and check out
other cool videos that I played in the
past in the description below and as
always I will see you all so thanks for
watching in the next video bye bye said
a UFO power